hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today's Thursday it is dead stream
recap day welcome back guys haven't seen
you in a while been doing a lot of
monster stuff I apologize but I've been
really enjoying the game and I'm
starting I'm trying to get into that
community of monster honor I can't only
do for hunter but like I always say I'm
going to stick with for honor until this
game is officially stopped updating so
once again dev stream recap coming in
with some season 5 weapons new content
of the week and some in-depth look at
the Highlander and Nobu she changes
coming at the beginning of season 5 with
conquer Ken Saiyan Berserker details
coming next week so let's get started so
first up conquer superior block is back
in the game
remember how we talked about how it was
supposed to come out of the air was
supposed to come with the rework changes
but accidentally got leaked in well they
reverted it back so not conquer has a
superior block but like I'll you know
it's gonna eventually disappear after
the two weeks it's going the actual
rework patch when season 5 actually
releases it's going to disappear again
like it was originally so we're only
gonna be getting it for two weeks so
definitely if you're a conqueror player
enjoyed the superior block while you
have it and then like I said Kent's a
conquer and Berserker changes are gonna
be coming in more detailed stuff next
week and Highlander or Nobu she were
talked about this week I'm not entirely
sure if they're gonna be talking more
about them next week but there was a lot
of stuff to talk about with these two
but that will be toward the end the new
event order it this week is supposed to
be to get as many executions as possible
so definitely do that if you have the
time this week the content of the week
for the next two weeks this week is the
free room of Sports emotes for the DLC
characters the original cast already had
them like the skiing and wardens the
cross stuff and stuff like that the
original cast had them but the DLC guys
didn't so they did give that so if we do
play one of the DLC characters you got
new emotes this week and next week is
new executions they didn't have a video
for this but they did show a teaser
image showing during the stream every
hero was supposed to get an execution
but they couldn't fit all of them on
screen so they only showed six of them
so if that's one of your characters you
go to a sneak peak before next week I'll
try to I'll see if I should make a video
next week showing off the executions or
not but either way continuing on the
devs talk about what they were going to
see at launch and what they stated is
that at launch
hero updates and reworks are gonna be
coming out XP boosts gear refinement the
factory war territory update and rep 50
is supposed to be releasing at the start
of season 5 and during season 5 were
supposed to beginning the trials and
arena training mode as long as well as
dedicated servers and input lag
compensation next up is the news is the
new season 5 weapon skins obviously they
didn't show every single weapon for
every single character according to what
the dev said there are three sets of
weapons and they only showed one set for
each of the characters with tons more to
come of course at the release but this
is for a teaser and I grabbed some of
the screenshots from the stream the
first four or the first batch of weapons
are gonna be seeing our conquer conquer
gladiator law bringer and no bushi and
the last four I grabbed our Musha
warlord Valkyrie and shaman like I said
every single character is getting them
and there's three different sets so if
you don't like let's say you're a
warlord player and you're not really
like in the shield he gets trust me
there's two other sets of weapons types
of skin so you might like those as well
but those are what they look like I
think they look absolutely phenomenally
good like the art team is so good at
their job they always make these look
good but next up they talked about the
fighting changes come in to season five
with one of the game designers Perry
changes are being balanced out to make
the risk of parrying and being more
rewarding also making it a little bit
harder to do I will have a video playing
in the background if you don't
understand what I mean but now if you
are parried in the opponent guard breaks
you you can now counter guard break
originally this wasn't what was allowed
originally if you were to get parried
and guard broken you couldn't GP out of
it now you are allowed to counter guard
break out of a parry next up is a little
bit of a change to what you're getting
guaranteed if your heavy attack is
parried the opponent will get a free
light attack and if a light attack is
parried the opponent will get a free
heavy really say really simple really
easy just a little bit of a flop there
so now it's more beneficial to go after
light attacks and get that free heavy
what lights are obviously harder to
parry than heavy so that's where that
risk more risk more reward comes in it's
like I previously stated it's gonna be a
lot harder but the rewards are gonna be
way better and then next up is character
changes there was a few things regarding
Berserker a little bit
Orochi and a little bit of shoe goki but
the main deal of this was highlander and
Nobu she
but to start berserker can now not get
top-heavy off of every single attack now
off a parry off a wall all that good
stuff he cannot get those anymore
Highlanders fast flow into offensive
form is now slightly slower so he won't
be able to get the unblockable heavy off
of a heavy parry orochi's top light
combo is now going to do 22 damage
instead of 35 but as a compensation for
that the wind gust is now 35 damage
instead of 25 and his Riptide strike is
now 40 instead of 30 making those two
moves better and his top light which is
basically his bread and butter a little
bit weaker so that orochi's can use more
moves and as well with the addition of
the parry changes getting parried from
the Riptide strike and all that won't be
as punishing as it originally was
next up shougo key will now and get
heavies off of a light parry because of
the parry changes as well and like I
said these may sound odd at first but
there are tons more coming with these
changes and they will probably go way
more in depth next week but now on to
Highlander and for Highlander the
including the Celtic curse dodge forward
heavy if you do the dodge forward heavy
instead of continuing and flowing with
the attack if you hold the heavy button
it will now allow you to cancel the
attack and flat a fast flow into
offensive form faking out the opponent
and when using the side attack for
Celtic curse you can now lock on to a
different opponent mid attack and then
hit them instead to change up if you're
in a gank situation you can now also
regen stamina and offensive form this
was never the case and his unblockable
heavy or Balor's might now cost 24
stamina instead of 30 so a decent buff
the Highlander and as well for a damage
buff all of his heavies are getting an
increased image from about 5 to 10
damage this was supposed to help trading
a lot for the Highlander mains and the
second light in his defensive combo
which is probably the most useless
attack he has has reduced recovery
frames and hyper armor to make
Highlanders now use that move more and
lastly the tracking on his grab and kick
are a little bit better since they
weren't that great to start with and
super easy to dodge one of the problems
is that people would or the Highlanders
would kick and then they obviously the
opponent would dodge the kick and
obviously what you would do is you would
fake the kick into the grab but they
would dodge the kick and the grab making
that whole thing useless because of
shady tracking
so they're going to fix that and then
next up is Nobu she's changes her zone
attack now is now 20 damage instead of
33 for the very first attack remember
the first attack is the super fast one
but to compensate now her kick is a lot
faster also when you land Nobu she's
kick you don't lose as much stamina as
before her side light finishers are now
a hundred milliseconds faster and her
side dodged recovery is now a hundred
milliseconds slower from 600 instead of
500 her sprint attack heavy will now
allege opponents but the light attack
sprint will not anymore
LED attacks after hidden stance will not
do 8 damage as opposed to 18 because of
the spam of this movement how easy it
was to land and the last thing is for
warden now this is a pretty big change
actually warden now cannot get gee bead
off of a zone attack if it is blocked
originally now in the current game if
you were to block a warden's own attack
you would just get a free GB and then
you could do whatever your character
does whether that's a side heavy top
heavy any of that type of jazz but now
in in season 5 if you block his Jeep or
if you block his own attack you will no
longer be able to guard break him from
it now I just want to preface this don't
be crying out saying that these are too
many buffs or too many nerfs or too
little changes let's let the changes
come out and then if something is bad
then we will judge it accordingly but
only after these release and then to end
the stream was another miscellaneous
patch note and then now in skirmish
instead of spawning like normal you will
now spawn in waves with your team to
have more group fights and prevent the
one on for fights if one team is
dominating the other obviously this is a
pretty decent change but not many people
do play skirmish so it isn't an
incredible change but once again it's
still a change nonetheless may be making
skirmish a little bit of a better mode
and when that guys that is going to be
the end of the video today I hope you
guys did enjoy I'm glad to be finally
back doing the for honor stuff obviously
I do those dub stream recaps and I
wanted something to fill that the gap
between it so that's why I was doing
Monster Hunter so I'm sorry if you
thought I was leaving for honor I'm
clearly not I love you guys a lot if you
guys did enjoy the video please sure to
give it a like really does help me out
subscriber from your new for honor I
cover the news the least the discussion
and the informational side of for honor
that's all I cover and my two most
recent videos are gonna be popping up on
screen thank you guys for watching the
video thank you for continuing to
support me and with that guys hope you
have a great rest of your day and peace
out